(phone ringing)
- Yo, it's GaryVee
here on #AskGaryVee Show
with Adam Braun,
what's your name?
- [CJ] Ah,
you kiddin' me, man!
- [Gary] Not joking.
(laughter)
- [CJ] Yo,
my name is CJ Reynolds,
I teach in West Philadelphia.
- [Gary] Born and raised?
- [CJ] You know,
on the playground.
(laughter)
- I love it, CJ.
How are you?
- [CJ] I'm doing great, man.
I'm sitting here
watching your feed
and I'm waiting for the
next question to be done
so I can know if
you were gonna call.
- Well, guess what, you won.
- [CJ] My sister's
coming in the room
to ask me for
something real quick.
- Alright.
- [CJ] Give me ten seconds,
I'll be right with you.
- You got it. 10, nine ...
- [CJ] Alright,
so here's my question.
I have students that
I teach in West Philadelphia,
I teach at an all boys school,
and we're talking like
inner-city Philadelphia
and I'm gonna
show them this feed.
And what I would
love to show them
is you giving them some advice
as to what to do
after high school
if they don't
want to go to college.
Because, coming
from me, it's like-
- [Gary] Yeah, you're a
teacher, you're the teacher.
- [Mr. Reynolds]
...over and over again.
I'm the teacher, I teach
ninth grade literature.
I actually hit you up on Twitter
a while ago when
you were looking for--
- [Gary] Oh,
schools to come action, yep.
Do we have them, right?
- [CJ] (Unintelligible)
- [Gary] Go ahead, okay.
- [CJ] So what could you speak
to my students to kinda give
them something to, you know.
They're not just hearing me,
but they know who you are,
they watch your videos in
class, they keep asking me
so like I'm always
giving them your information
and telling them what
I think you would say,
but I would love for you
to speak to them
directly if you could.
- I could.
Now, give me, help me
a little bit here,
because the truth is,
let's start from the top.
- [CJ] So a lot of my guys
have been literally
punched in the mouth
many times in their lives,
and so it's about like
helping them to see that
there's kinda more to themselves
or that they have
more to offer, than, um...
You know, they've kinda
been beaten down already,
and some guys
seem a little bit--
- Do they have the
chip on their shoulder
that somebody owes them
something because
it was fucked up,
or do they have no
self-esteem because
everybody told
them they can't win.
- [CJ] Both.
You know, it's a both.
- That's exactly right.
- [CJ] We're talking about boys,
so it's an all boys
school where, you know,
90 percent of my guys
don't have a dad at home.
- Yep.
- [CJ] Which literally,
it makes my job easier,
because, you know,
you're a guy that
shows up every day
that tells kids you love them
and that you see them and
that they're not invisible.
- Hey Reynolds, can
I ask you a question?
If I paid for the bus, like
I know schools are fucked up
so they can't take advantage...
But if I paid for the bus, can
you bring like eight or nine
of them up here and
hang with me for an hour?
Let's take them out,
do some fucking contests,
Reynolds do whatever
the fuck you gotta do
to pick eight or nine of them,
bring them up here,
we'll jam with them,
we'll film that,
and then you can use it.
- [CJ] One, two, three,
four, five, six.
(applause)
Guys that I identify as being
someone that I think could,
like, hear what this
guy has to talk about,
and also that
could use the talk, also.
And I'm not saying
like your life is awful,
you're down in life,
it's tough for you, right?
But like, I know
some dudes' stories,
I've talked to guys
like Kev, Nate, and stuff,
and all of you have
something different going on,
but I just think this
is a chance of a lifetime.
- [Gary] Reynolds, I can't
wait to fucking see you.
You better get
your ass here soon.
The season's almost over.
- [CJ] Yeah, man.
- I'll see you soon.
I'll see you next week.
- [CJ] Thank you.
- Let's figure it out. See ya.
(gentle piano music)
- We're on our way
up now, we're leaving.
On our way, here we
go, to New York City.
(piano music)
Alright, we made it to New York.
Tyler's coming to get us now
and then we'll
go to VaynerMedia.
(chill pop music)
- [CJ] We're thrilled
to be here, man.
Thanks so much
for even having us.
That was a,
- [Gary] You fucking
hacked me, bro.
- So, well, you know,
(laughter)
anything I can do
for these dudes is,
you know, I'll
try it, anyway, so.
And we were laughing that
when I got the call-in show,
I was like flubbing my words,
my kids were
asking me for drinks,
and my dog was
coming in the room,
and I'm like just
trying to ask this question,
and so, you had,
I had said on the call-in,
I need like 10 seconds,
and I was talking to my son,
and you thought I
was talking to you,
and I was like, no, no this is,
(laughs)
just trying to work this out.
But yeah, man,
I'm gonna grab a seat.
- Cool, well listen, I'm
super glad you guys are here.
I really hit it off with
your teacher, professor here.
I mean, really, I couldn't
wait for this day to happen,
so I'm really happy you're here.
Listen, I'll be honest,
I can give you guys
a little context, I don't know,
do you guys have any idea who
I am, or anything about me?
- Yes.
- Okay, great, so
to be real honest,
I'd love to
maximize our time together,
answer shit for you.
Maybe I'll talk a little bit
just to create
some framework, right?
But, to me, I'd love to
just answer any questions
you guys might have,
or things of that nature.
Here's my perspective,
my big thing,
you know, what
caught my attention
about what you were
talking about, which is,
I'm fascinated by the
game of opportunity, right?
Like I think, when you get
into these conversations like,
who's got opportunity?
Who's born, who wins the lottery
of being born into a trust fund?
Who doesn't?
Who grows up in
a bad neighborhood?
Who grows up, there's
people that live in the Amazon.
There's so many,
there's a lot going on
with the 7.7 billion
people on Earth.
To me, the game of opportunity
is what's super fascinating.
And I think the internet
just fucked everything up
in the best way possible.
There's just so much more
opportunity than there ever was
for the people that
don't have the opportunity,
and to me, that's,
like fuck, that's something
you need to really wrap your
head around, and I say that
to people that have
everything handed to them,
and people that have
nothing handed to them.
It's kind of agnostic.
Now, where it
gets real interesting
for me with you guys,
and I'm making presumptions
based on the five minutes
we got to talk, but,
what's really interesting to me
is that I grew up an immigrant.
I didn't have much.
And I grew up
in a different time
than you guys are growing up,
where school was
the only way out.
Like, the only way
you could be successful,
when I was your age, the
only thing I had ever heard,
is the only way you
could ever be successful,
is if you go to Harvard,
and get a good job,
and this and that.
There was no talk
of entrepreneurship.
There was no talk of hustle,
flipping shit, making shit,
nothing, zero.
Zero conversation.
And there was
definitely no internet.
So, for me, what's
really, really crazy is
I think the people
that have the advantage now,
have the chip on their shoulder,
have the flip mentality,
have the quick score,
the salesmanship, the
stuff that I associate more
with not the Upper East Side.
And I don't think
people understand that.
I don't think
people really understand
that the DNA of the hustle
and the grind and the flip
is actually about
to win way more now
than the kids that think
they're gonna go by the books
and go through the system.
And that should be
the greatest fucking thing
you've ever heard in your life
if you actually believe me.
So that's like my energy, that's
why I wanted to have this.
If I can get one
of you fucking kids
to actually believe me, then
this is ROI positive for me.
Then I'll get some good
email from you in 15 years
and be like, yo
that was a good trip,
I'm really glad you said that.
It changed my mindset.
That's really what I'm
trying to get out of here.
And I wish, I think you
guys know something about me,
you don't know me,
I don't know you, right?
I wish you knew how
much I believe that.
How much, I could give a
fuck to inspire some kids,
I'm being really
serious with you.
I'm not checking a box
to feel good about myself,
or do the right thing.
I just believe it.
And I think it would
be ROI positive for me
because I actually think one
of you guys is gonna hear me,
go do shit, and then wanna
do shit with me in 10 years,
and do business together.
So, I just really,
really wanna make sure
I set the stage
for this conversation.
I'm not checking any boxes here,
other than being selfish because
I actually believe
in what I'm saying,
believe you guys
actually have the advantage
that you don't realize,
and just think
that's gonna manifest,
and it's gonna work out
for me in 15 or 20 years.
That's my truth.
So, and I think
that's powerful, right?
When I think
about that, I'm like,
that's way cooler than,
I wanna be a nice
guy and help some school,
like, nobody wants pandering.
(chuckles)
Right?
Who, you don't want pandering.
The number one thing in life
that I've fought my whole life
was handouts or, like I
went into my dad's family
liquor store business
when I knew I could have done
bigger things, just to make
sure I never had it over my head
that he did good by me.
I needed to check that
box and be even with him.
So, I'm visceral
to anybody
doing anything for me.
The only thing
I wanna do for you here,
is to wake you the fuck up
of how much advantage
you have against the market.
Because, you got one of these?
Then you're in the game.
If you don't,
that's different.
If you don't own a smartphone,
then I get quiet.
But if you do,
you're in the game.
In a real way.
You know?
You guys know this,
there's fucking kids
flipping fucking
sneakers on Instagram
making more money than
half the fucking people
that work for
me in this company.
But are you willing to
wake up at 4:30 in the morning
and be online for two hours?
You know what to do.
We know,
it's just people
aren't willing to work.
It's a binary game,
but it's real.
It's so real,
it's crazy.
You know, I was
on Breakfast Club
and Envy called me out...
You see that?
- [Group] Yeah.
- You guys saw that?
- Yep.
- Did you see the part where
Envy was like, "Okay, cool,
"stop motivating,
give me something real."
And I was like,
"Go to the Dollar Store
"and buy shit and
sell it on eBay."
That whole thing,
it turned into this whole thing,
I started this video of me
called the 2017 Flip Challenge.
I'm gettin' the
craziest fuckin' emails.
Like, just people that are like
"I'm on welfare,
"I make $5 an hour,
"and now I'm goin' to Marshall's
"and making $1000 a week."
Just real.
I just think people
aren't willing to work.
I think it's much more fun
to be mad at the system.
My employees
love to be mad at me.
(group laughter)
They love blaming me,
they love blamin' me.
They're like, "It's
fucked up 'cause of..."
I'm like, "No, no...
Here's what's
actually happening."
And they're like, "Oh."
You know, we fired 60 people,
because I felt the company
was gettin' fat and slow.
And so, I fired 60 people.
One guy, that night,
came up to me.
And he was like, "You
said 'we fired people because
we're fat and slow and
not workin' hard enough,'
fuck you."
Like, I have good
relationships with my emp...
You can see my vibe, right?
They feel comfortable
saying shit like that to me.
Literally, he
was like "Fuck you,
"me and my team,
"we're workin'
fuckin' 13 hours a day."
I said, "I know."
I said, "The
reason you're workin'
"13 hours a day
is 'cause you guys
"aren't gettin' rid
of the eight people
"on your team that suck shit
"'cause you're
friends with them."
So, you know,
that's just the truth, right?
So, to me,
here's the truth
in your situation;
you could make a lot of money
and live whatever the
fucking life you want.
As long as you got this,
because this is so
ridiculously powerful.
And nobody gives a fuck
who you are on this.
You don't have
to impress anyone,
you don't have
to have the grades,
you can do nothing.
I think that's powerful.
And whether that means you wanna
story tell,
be in fashion,
flip stuff,
there's just...
There's just no excuse anymore.
And I think it's liberating,
once you actually believe in it.
When you realize that
nobody gets to decide your shit,
shit gets real fun.
You know?
Because, I'm empathetic,
I'm empathetic, man.
I get it.
Like, I don't really get it
'cause you gotta
live it to really get it,
but I'm pretty
close for the way I look,
and I get it.
It's just real.
It's powerful.
So, I just think that
there's shit to be done.
And what's really interesting
is all my friends...
You know,
I was a real bad student.
I went to a college
called Mount Ida College,
where 94%, 96% of the kids
were African American or Latino.
That's where I
probably got my permission
to have a little swag, right?
(group laughter)
And so, that's where I spent
my four years on, right?
So, I met kids...
I have friends...
My suitemate is
in jail in Newark
for the rest of
his life for double murder.
I slept with my wallet.
It was pretty fucked up
where I went to college.
And when I think
about what those...
My friends, my friends,
the kids that
were in my wedding,
the opportunities they had,
'cause they looked your part,
compared to what you have.
It's fucking crazy.
It's crazy.
That's it.
Some dude e-mailed
me, he had 11 dollars
when he heard the Envy thing.
Eleven.
He's making a
thousand dollars a month now.
Marshalls and T.J. Maxx.
He just listened to me.
Downloaded the
Amazon app instead of
playing Madden
for four hours a day.
He goes to
T.J. Maxx and Marshalls
and he scans
every fucking product.
And with the first eleven dol--
Eleven.
First eleven dollars, he
bought some sort of shirt
that was four dollars cost,
and he sold it for 17 on eBay,
and he built the whole thing.
- [Man] Yeah.
- It's crazy.
Just real.
- [Woman] And he
scanned it with an app,
with knowing--
- Yeah, yeah.
Download the Amazon
app, you scan stuff,
you see what it costs, right?
- [Woman] Oh.
I mean, look,
actually, fuck, you're here.
Tell them.
Tell them who you are,
and what you're doing here.
- Well, I actually met Gary
through the 2017--
- (Gary laughs)
- Flip Challenge.
I was, my family came from
Russia, like his parents did.
I was born and raised in
Brooklyn, high school dropout.
- I came from Russia, too.
- Yeah.
- I was born there.
- Pops died when
I was 12 years old.
High school dropout.
Wasted my 20s,
pretty much, just chilling
and doing nothing productive.
Five years ago, I got
into the Amazon game,
just hustling and flipping and
putting in those long hours,
14, 15-hour days.
I had less than
$11 when I started.
I was $100,000 in debt,
owed the IRS money,
just lost friends, my girlfriend
kicked me out of the house.
Five years doing
Amazon, I grossed
$14 million
in sales last year.
- [Man] That's called
retail arbitrage, right?
- There's a lot of different
business models that you can do.
One of them is retail arbitrage,
where you just go
into stores and scan
what they have in the store,
see what it's selling for
on Amazon and eBay, and there
might be a little profit.
You might find
something for 10, and someone's
selling it on
Amazon or on eBay for 20,
and there might be
three, four bucks left in it,
profit for you, and
you just scale that out.
You go from one item to
two, to five, to 10, to 20,
and you build an
awesome business for yourself.
- [Gary] You get lucky, right?
Luck plays into it.
You go to a
dollar store, they got
some weird thing by accident,
you buy it for a dollar,
it's going for $11,
and all of a sudden,
you can buy 40 of them?
You know, it can add up.
- [Man] Yeah,
but it sounds easy,
and it sounds sexy,
- [Gary] Oh, it's super hard.
- But the most
important thing is the hustle,
you know, like he
said, this guy with 11 bucks
was waking up at 4 A.M.
- [Gary] Yeah, you gotta go
to T.J. Maxx, buy something,
take it home, post it,
get it on Amazon or eBay,
ship it for $4, people
are like, "Fuck that," right?
That's what people are, "Fuck
that," without realizing
that once you
get your game tight--
- [Man 2] You're
doing that at scale.
- Yeah, you can do it at scale.
You also start
getting an eye, right?
Like, I just even look at
the jacket you're wearing,
I'm like, okay,
this kid, he should be
going to thrift
stores, using his eye,
buying shit for
two bucks, and then
marketing it on Etsy for 29
as fucking, you know, fashion.
- [Man] Yeah, my
average profit on an item
was probably four, five
bucks, but you start out--
- [Gary] What'd you start with?
- In terms of what kind
of items do you start with?
- [Gary] So,
five years ago, what's
the first fucking thing you did?
- My boy owned a
salon, a beauty salon,
and he was doing
Amazon with beauty products
that he was getting
through his beauty salon.
He gave me a job,
I went to work for him.
I was taking the catalogs of
different wholesale suppliers
that he was working with,
and just doing the arbitrage,
seeing what they're selling
for from the wholesalers,
and what they're
selling for on Amazon,
and just picking out
the 1% of items that make,
you know, four bucks,
five bucks, and you would
add that to your
list, and you'd go from,
you know, one sale a
day to two sales a day,
and to five sales a day.
We'll probably be doing over
1,000 sales a day right now,
and, you know, it's peanuts,
four or five bucks an item,
but when you do it
on scale, it adds up.
And I was able to build a
awesome business.
- [Gary] I saw
something on your
social, like, at first,
you packed it in your
house, then you had it
in your backyard,
now you have a warehouse.
- [Man] When I started,
we rented a little
two-bedroom house
that was probably the
size of this conference room,
and we were just
working out of that room,
just me and my boy,
buying stuff, packing stuff,
shipping stuff to
Amazon all day long,
12, 14, 15 hours a
day, and just scaled that,
just kept going.
- [CJ] Let me ask you this.
- [Gary] Yeah?
- [CJ] Because we've
been, one of the things
we've been talking about
on the way up here is--
- [Gary] Anybody want anything?
- Need something? Good?
- I have a YouTube channel
and I started DMing people,
and seeing like you
talk about this before,
like seeing what
you could do for others,
and so I started--
- [Gary] You started
sliding into the DM?
(group laughter)
- So I figure if I
can get into bigger media
who else can I get in with.
So I started
sending all these DM's out
and True Value
Hardware store gets back to me
and I said "I'll
make you five free videos.
"It's me and my students,
"and we have a
carpentry after school program.
"I just want to show you,
"this is what we're
doing with your product.
"You're where we buy
all our supplies from
"and let me try to
do something for you."
And so they
emailed me back and said,
"Yeah we want to try and
do a partnership with you."
And I have a phone
call set up for tomorrow
that has to do with that.
What that means
to these guys is,
some of them, like
these guys do music,
Elijah's into
fashion, and so, obviously.
(group laughter)
So, like, trying to
sort of build a brand
and then start DMing people,
or one of the other
things we've been talking about
is how you're
always saying how to,
kind of like
chronical what you're doing.
Like recording the journey.
Because how amazing
would that look if like
Eminem started when he
was 12 and was writing rhymes
and then like all
that footage existed now
would be unbelievable to
watch that kind of thing, so.
- [Gary] The answer's yes.
Right?
Like yes to all
the shit you just said.
- [CJ] I told you guys.
(group laughter)
- Because you just
regurgitated my shit.
(group laughter)
Yeah I mean look.
I think they
should DM every single,
every single music
producer in the world
that they want to
fuck with and say,
"Look, we're starting out.
"I'll come and fucking clean."
Prince was a janitor.
You remember when I said that?
I believe in that shit so much.
Fucking Prince wanted it so
bad he fucking cleaned up shit
in exchange for studio time
and then he was good enough.
They may get Metro Boomin to
like let 'em clean up his shit
and that's where they are,
and they may not be good
enough so they would lose,
but it would give them a chance.
But you can't, you
can't do what every kid does,
which is hit up these big
time producers and be like,
"Yo my shit's fire,
listen to my shit."
They get that
50,000 times a day.
You need to give people shit.
You know what you have?
You have time.
Like every
person's got somethin'.
And what you definitely have
at this age is you have time.
That's your asset.
Your time and what you
do with it is what you got.
And so if you want to
get into the music game,
I would hit up every single
person in the game, DM them,
DMing on
Instagram is unstoppable.
It is the move.
DM 20, 30 people then if you
get banned for a couple hours
you start again later, right?
And you just hit
up people and be like,
you could intern for the biggest
fashion brand of all time
this summer, you just
have to ask 500 of them.
And only one's
gonna say "kinda."
It's a numbers game.
You know?
- [Woman] Can
I ask you a question?
- [Gary] Of course!
- [Woman] You talk a lot
about self-awareness
and knowing yourself.
What does that
mean for young people
that have had a
hard life or deal with
a lot of different things that
kinda kids shouldn't
deal with at this age.
So I know self-awareness
in like knowing yourself,
but how do you, like
what are your thoughts
when you're trying
to figure out yourself
and you have to
kind of deal with
the baggage in your life.
You know I never hear
you talk about counseling
or anything like that
so I'm just wondering like,
your thoughts on,
more about self-awareness
for these guys
I'm interested in.
- [Gary] Look I think
people that are growing up
in the best
environments of all time
are struggling with
self-awareness at 13 and 14.
I mean, 90%, 98% of my company
are in their 30's and 40's
and 20's have no
clue on self-awareness.
So here's what I would say.
I would say that I'm a big
fan of just eating reality.
I'm just a fan of it you know?
Like the
reality was I was never,
like my dad I had
my dad but I didn't.
'Cause he worked
every hour, never saw him.
Missed every game
just didn't see him.
Worked every hour.
That was my reality,
now I was happy it was
way better than him leaving
or dying or you
know it was great.
But like I didn't have him.
I could have done
what my other friends
who have workaholic
parents do and dwelled.
Be like my dad's
not at my baseball game.
Or you don't.
Look I am not
going to short change
the extremities of all the
things you know all the cliches.
Parents, drugs,
murder, mental health,
like all the things.
The thing that
I have not figured out
is how to get the
universe to give a fuck.
So to answer your
question it's amazing
to see people in good situations
and bad situations go through
a situation and do this.
Like if I could
give everybody a drug
it would be optimism.
Right like if
you're willing to look
at all your shit whatever it is.
And by the way
everybody thinks their shit
is the shit right
like everybody's like
I've had people sit
in this room one by one
with me say if my didn't give
me $100 hundred million
I would have never been a loser
'cause it all
came too easy to me.
Everybody thinks
their shit's the shit.
'Cause it's their life right?
People that don't have parents
they laugh at that
they're like fuck you.
But that person
thinks that's the shit.
So it's about you
know I don't know.
I don't talk about a
lot of things I don't know.
I don't know how to
recommend counseling
or how to build
self-awareness or mental health,
I try to stay away from
things that I don't know
'cause I think that
would be detrimental
to the things I do know.
What I will say is
you know self-aware...
So I don't know how
to teach self-awareness.
I just know it's the game.
Once you know who you are it
manifests into self esteem.
You don't actually
then give a fuck you know
you sit here and just
don't give a fuck what they say
or any girl says
you just don't care.
It's crazy when you get there.
That's like the
fuckin' ultimate you're
just fuckin' living
life in like the Matrix.
You're just like
runnin' through shit.
To actually not give a,
especially at this age,
that's what happened to me.
I still think about it.
How the fuck did
I not give a fuck?
(group laughter)
Right? Because when
you're like 13, 14, 15,
that's your whole life.
I just remember not caring and I
just I was just on some
different shit in my head.
So that's what
I want for everybody.
Because then you're fuckin' set.
- [Man 4] How
do you get there?
- I don't know man that's why
I don't talk about it right?
Like I just
honestly I swear to got
if I knew how to
get there this whole
thing would be a wrap I'd own
the Jets I'd own the world
if I know how to
like get there and
get people there, right?
I try to get there
by talking about it
and maybe
somebody's like oh shit
that's kinda like me too,
let me go deeper into that.
I actually do feel like that,
I actually don't give a fuck.
Like I don't
know but
God it's big,
'cause then peer pressure's out.
Then you're just
not getting dragged
into anything you
don't wanna be doing.
- [Woman 2] Can
I ask a question.
- Yeah please.
- So Nate I'm gonna call you
out a little bit on this.
So what do you do or
when you're talking to someone
and trying to figure
out what their passion is
and I know you talk a lot about
what your passion is of how
do you spend your time right?
So in speaking to
our guys and they're like
I don't know what I wanna do or
I'm not really in
to anything kind of
what is your advice for them?
- [Gary] Listen
I get that fuckin',
my first book was called How
to Cash in on Your Passion.
Which fucked me up
because then everybody
kept emailing me
like what's my passion?
Like I don't fucking know you
like I don't know,
like I have now idea.
The biggest thing
you realize is a lot
of people don't
know or never find it
or you know my
belief is the only answer
for any of them right,
for you for anybody is you gotta
figure out how to try shit.
Like that's the only,
like you just never know
what you're favorite food
was until you tried it.
If you only had
chicken you might have
not known that
hot dogs were the best.
So that's what
I love about the internet
these kids have so much option
to like watch
shit on YouTube and my
only answer to Nate or anybody
is just like
try shit and so like
that's back to opportunity.
Easy to try shit
when you have hundreds
of thousands of
dollars in the bank.
And parents that
take you to shit.
You gotta hack the game right?
Like that's
what's passionate for me
about this today.
This is me letting them try
shit here in a different way.
Something could
happen who knows?
Maybe not I'm
willing to go 0 for nine.
But you try.
So like that to
me that's why I love
the DM thing
right like you don't
think 21 Savage
is hitting you back,
but he might.
Crazy shit happens.
People decide
no before they try.
You just decided no because
the system tells you no.
You've been sold no.
And by the way not just you,
the fuckin' world.
Not tough situation,
the world.
Everybody's saying no.
I just say yes,
and then if it's a no,
I don't give a fuck.
You gonna judge me that I lost?
I don't give a
fuck what you think.
And that's why
I get so into that,
because then you're
not scared to try shit
because when you don't
give a fuck what anybody says
about you failing,
you love failing.
I love losing.
It is crazy.
(group laughter)
- [Woman] You say
that all the time
and it literally,
it is crazy that you say it!
- [Gary] I love it!
- All the time,
because with him and YouTube,
and it's like we
partner on this, you know,
and I hate being on
camera, it's like not my thing.
So he does that
and I do a lot of
social media stuff
and things like that in
partnering with him, but--
- [Gary] You're
thinking about distribution.
- It bums me when
something doesn't work
or when we think
it's gonna be great
and the idea of
loving the failure,
it always just bums me out.
- [Gary] I love getting
punched in the mouth.
I love it, I love it,
I love it, I love it.
- [Woman] What is
it about the failure
that you love or,
that drives you?
- It makes me want to stick it
to everybody who judged
me when they judged my fail.
- [Woman] And that is true,
I like that part.
- Well that's it.
I like it m--
no, no.
I actually love it,
you just kind of like it.
(group laughter)
- [Woman] I don't
think I understand it yet.
- You know, yeah.
- [Woman] We haven't
scored that big.
- Yeah, I get it, I get it.
To me it's--
yeah.
It's like, It's a
chip on my shoulder.
I loved being an underdog.
I loved being from Russia
and not speaking English
and being small--
like, somewhere
around third grade, I'm like,
"Fuck I'm not gonna
be as good at sports
"as these other kids are
getting real fucking tall."
Like you know, just like
I just loved it
and I still love it.
And it's really
funny now that I've made it
in my little space
I wanna do other shit.
'Cause I don't wanna--
as soon as I won
the wine game, I left.
'Cause I don't
wanna be the top dog.
I don't want
people trying to get me.
I want to try and get them.
You know?
I love the grind.
I love--
you like that?
(group laughter)
- That's tough, that's tough
it's really true too
because it's like
when you're at the top
it's like there's
no where else to go.
- [Gary] It sucks.
- Everybody is
right at your neck
but when you're
always reaching for the top,
then it's like
that constant grind--
- [Gary] And
I gotta tell you, man,
and I'm telling you, my friend,
this.
This is the operating
system of the universe.
This is the only
thing that matters.
The attention on
this is the game.
And like, that just--
like you could make
an instagram account.
Like go ahead.
This one kid I'm
watching him Musical.ly,
he went from zero to
a hero in four-minutes,
five videos.
- [Man 5] The problem that we
have promoting our stuff
like on Instagram,
everyone is trying
to promote and stuff.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So like--
we're not getting
heard because of that.
So how do you avoid that?
- [Gary] You don't avoid it.
You start doing different shit.
You're doing what
everybody else is doing.
Let's put up a post.
He listened to me and hit up,
DMed this hardware store,
now something good happened.
You know what
I would do if I were you?
I would hit up everybody
who's making funny videos,
and offer them free music.
- Cool. That was my idea.
(group laughter)
- That's what I was thinking.
- That's great, man.
- [Gary] Guys,
you need exposure.
If you get some booty girl
to twerk behind your music,
it could happen.
You just need
people to hear it. Right?
If you've got
somebody like Big Juan
or somebody
with a funny account,
who just uses your
beat or uses your song
as the background music
to the clip
they're trying to put on.
But you have the--
here's the thing, here's
the thing that I--
back to losing,
that I understood,
when I was low
nobody high gave a fuck.
So I wasn't going
to people who were high
and said, "Do something for me."
I was going to
people that were high
and saying, "This is
what I'm gonna do for you."
And that's why I try
to get people into the
nobody gives a fuck
about your problems mentality
'cause then you don't
roll up on people asking
or thinking that.
Nobody's gonna
put you on just 'cause.
They're gonna put you on
because they needed a beat
for their shit,
you just gave them one.
- [Man 7] Damn, that's crazy.
- [Man 8] Yeah.
- What else are you guys into
like what else is in your world,
what are you thinking about?
- Like me.
- Yeah.
- Me, personally?
- Please.
- Like since me
coming into high school
I developed like so many times,
like contracting, I used
to do sneaker things,
design art, so I'm like,
I really don't know
what direction to go
because I have so many talents
but it's just like,
so many capabilities,
so I'm just like,
right now, just living.
Just see what's going on.
I'm doing opportunities,
like I be tryin' to do sneakers,
tryin' to get a
clothing line started,
tryin' to do a whole lot of
stuff, but it's just like--
- Are you enjoying it?
- Actually, what I really enjoy,
I'm a mentor.
Like helping people.
- Yeah.
- So that's what I'm
really trying to get into.
But right now, I really
don't know my direction,
so like I'm just--
- Maybe that's the direction,
a lot of time I think
the doing is the direction.
Right?
The reason I asked
you if you were happy is
if it's going good
like if you're happy,
there is almost nothing to say.
Right, like?
I think, you know,
I think taste--
when I hear that, that was
just what I said earlier right?
Like try shit.
If you're mentoring
and sneakers and (mumbles),
you're doing shit.
If you're actually doing it.
To me, the thing
is, I know a kid.
A friend of mine who's
had a similar thing and
I was like cool and I like
asked one more question,
I realized he was doing
it for 45 minutes a day.
But he had crazy ambitions.
How many hours a day?
- [Man] 15, 16?
- Yeah, you know
like, that's the only way.
Now you got school
and you got some other
shit you gotta take care of.
But there's a lot of time.
- [Man] Can I add something?
- Please, you just
went through living it.
- So if you don't
fail on your next five,
10, 15 attempts at whatever,
you're not gonna
get to that next step
to find what you love.
So if you just
here and thinking about
what am I gonna do?
What am I good at?
What's my passion?
And never actually do
something, you'll get nowhere.
But if you say, let me try this.
I'd love to see
if you gain or fail--
Good, you'll be done with it
and you'll go on to the
next and on to the next.
And if you look at
the one thing I've noticed
and I'm sure
you guys will agree,
from anyone who's
successful in anything,
whether it's a
business guy like Gary
or an artist or anyone of--
anybody who's successful,
the one thing
they all have in common
is they fail 99% of the time
before they have a hit song,
before they
have a good business,
before anything--
- [Gary] Or, or, or
they just worked, right?
Like I would
tell you straight up,
I didn't fail a
whole lot other than school
'cause I knew that's
what I was not gonna do.
It's just that
people don't realize
that Lebron
fucking took 4,000 shots
a day in 4th grade.
You know, like what do
you think they're doing?
Like listen, you guys know
this is what I saw (mumbles).
Like fuck man.
Somebody's kids
are athletic freaks.
But then they were
just smoking blunts all day.
I was like they didn't make--
Now I understand.
They weren't waking up at
5:30 in the morning running,
fucking hitting the
gym and then shooting
for nine hours a day.
(stammers)
50% of the kids
in my suite, 301,
they're like I'm
gonna be a rapper.
Like--
They didn't write all day.
They never tried
to get into studio.
They didn't do shit.
They talked shit.
Gotta do.
- [Man] Worst thing you
can do is do nothing.
- Pondering, complaining.
Dreaming.
It's one and the same.
If you're dreamin' or
if you're complainin',
it's the same shit.
It means you're
just not doing shit.
- [Woman] One of
the things that I love
that you often talk about is--
well, not often, I think
I've heard it like one,
one or two times--
is people do look at
it the famous people.
Whether it's a
celebrity, or a sports person,
or a musician and...
They kinda hate on them.
Like oh it was easier,
oh it was this or that,
they make excuses and kind of
hatin' on these people but--
- Like talent's real too.
Like serendipity happens.
Like.
Lil Yachty wasn't
doin' all that much work.
Wrote a couple of songs
in Arkansas State and went.
Happens.
It's not the norm.
But you know, listen.
Life is talent and work ethic.
Nothing else.
You can work 19
hours a day on beats.
If you're not good enough,
nothing good's gonna happen.
That's just real.
Which is why it's
important to try and taste shit
because you might be the
greatest fucking
cook of all time.
You might.
It's crazy.
It's really
fucking fucks with me.
And it like I'm trying
to figure it out myself.
I'm not Yoda.
I'm just trying to
figure it out too but like
it's there man.
And the internet makes it crazy.
Like you probably wouldn't
watch 700 videos of cooking
back in the day because
whatever played on cable,
played on cable, right?
But now you could.
Right? Like video games.
I'm trying to think back to
my days at the Ida--
there were some kids there
that could literally become
professional video game players.
That's now real.
People getting paid
millions to play video games.
There's so much opportunity
'cause of the internet.
- [Man 7] Can I
ask you a question?
- Of course, man.
- [Man 7] Who do you look up to?
What are you in to right now?
- [Gary] Yeah,
I was weird with that.
I was super ins, you know,
back to not giving a fuck,
it also
manifested the other way.
I didn't look at anybody.
You know,
I looked up to my parents.
They came to America with $100.
Lived in a studio apartment
with eight family
members in Queens.
You know, and I just
watched them grind in my face.
Every day.
We bought nothing.
I went on one family
vacation my whole life.
Right?
We bought nothing.
K-Mart and Bradleys for clothes.
You know, that's what we did.
My whole life.
My dad then eventually
had a little liquor store.
Literally, I wore
liquor t-shirts to school
every day of my life.
Like, you know?
So, I look up to them.
You know,
how hard they brought it.
And they built
the foundation, right?
I was lucky to
have parents like that.
But I never looked up, like oh
I want to be like Bill Gates
or I want to be like Steve Jobs.
I wanna be me.
That's my best.
I suck shit at so
much stuff, my man.
Like, suck.
But I go so hard
at what I'm good at.
And I'm gonna win the
whole thing 'cause of it.
- [Man 7] What is this spark?
I watched your
video where you said
you live every day
like it's your last
or like you're not coming back.
So what was that spark
that made you realize that?
- [Gary] I'm grateful.
I'm driven by gratitude.
And I wish everybody was.
Do you know how
ridiculously crazy it is
that you're a human being?
400 trillion to one.
You're more
likely to win the lotto
nine times in your life
than actually having a life.
Honestly, to be very
black and white on this,
I don't know how
we can't be thankful.
You could've been a tree.
I just look at
everything positive.
I get a phone call
right now, my mom died,
I'd be dead, like dead, right.
But then very quickly,
I'd be like I'm so grateful
that I had her, that
all this time we had.
You know what I mean?
I'm optimistic.
I'm grateful.
And I try to
impose that on people
who have more than me
and who have less than me.
Because it's the same game.
It's just you're gonna
choose how to look at life
and I think it's
chemicals that make you say,
"Fuck, my dad left
me when I was four,
"I'm in a bad neighborhood,
my brother got killed."
But I just meet kids who
have the same shit every day.
I said I gotta take
the family on my back
and I'm gonna do this and I'm
gonna make it to the league.
It's just binary.
Either you decide it's shit
or you decide
it's your advantage.
What I know, for facts.
This is facts.
Because of this and Instagram
and Snapchat and YouTube,
people that have
chips on their shoulder,
that come from shit,
have the advantage
'cause the work
ethic and the hunger
is now the biggest
factor in who's gonna win
and people like my kids,
who have everything, are soft.
I think that's it.
I don't think my kids wanna work
in a room half the size
of this for 16 hours a day.
Because they have a
house in the Hamptons.
They're just soft.
So it's crazy how,
I don't even say it
'cause I don't
think you'd believe it
and then you'd think I'm
saying it for some bullshit
so I don't say it.
But I'm gonna say it anyway.
I look, and I'm like,
these kids got the advantage.
They don't get it,
I know they don't think it,
and I'll never say it out loud
because the world would say,
"Fuck you, you're an idiot.
"How could you say that?"
I get it.
I don't give a fuck,
I know I'm right.
And when you
actually believe that,
shit can get so crazy.
If actually believed it,
and I, by the way.
I genuinely
believe if I had 900 kids
walk through here,
looked just like you,
like one, two, three,
would actually believe it.
Not wanna believe
'cause they think I'm right.
Not not believe it
because most people
will not believe it.
Like actually believe it.
They'll win.
- [CJ] That's one thing
you learn about teaching.
'Cause you see
that in kids, right.
Everyone in this room
got picked for a reason.
I have 400 some very
angry students at school
that, we were leaving soon,
no I checked that dude out,
how come you're not
taking me, Reynolds.
- [Gary] Oh, is that right?
- Oh, pissed, yeah.
Sad, walking like this.
(Gary chuckles)
- And so (laughs)
And so, like, as a
teacher, often, you see
the great stuff in kids,
and then to have them
not see the same thing like
they're not gonna buy it--
- [Gary] Of course, my
man, you know this,
because they go
outside your room,
and the rest of the world
is telling them "Fuck you."
- [CJ] Yeah.
- And they believe
the rest of the world.
- [Woman 2] But that's why they
have champions like you.
How many of these kids you
now have built relationships,
and that they
now see in themselves
what you saw in
them four years ago,
or two years ago,
or two years ago.
- [Man 5] Yeah, I did terrible
in his class in that year.
I just barely passed it.
This year, and
as close as we got,
and some of the words and
wisdom he'd given me and Gnarl
our music and stuff like that,
they just stick with me forever.
I think opportunities like this
you have no choice but to
really believe in yourself
and not just believe it
because you think
somebody is right.
I'm here, I'm in New York,
meeting with somebody was
very important and successful
and doesn't care about
what other people think.
And you see stuff like that,
you get those opportunities,
you have no choice
but to believe that stuff.
Because you gotta
understand what happened
to get you to this point.
- [Gary] It's cool, man.
It's fucking real opp,
it's just
experiences and opportunity.
What's real cool
for me, guys, is that
back 20 years ago, 25 years ago,
everybody in this circumstance
wanted to be an athlete
or a rapper, everybody.
And now that entrepreneurship
is getting cool, it's huge.
'Cause it's super-hard
to win in those games.
You have to
actually win the whole thing.
Like, you've gotta
go all the way there.
The 18,000th best
basketball player on Earth
works at UPS.
The 18,000th best
entrepreneur owns UPS.
And that's why I'm going all-in.
That's why I'm
sitting here right now.
I want to give back to the game.
You know, you give back to
the game that gets you there.
This entrepreneur thing,
I got Ds and Fs.
I promise you, straight up,
I was a worse student
than everybody in this room.
I was just a
non-existent student.
When you said barely
passed, I was laughing
because I was like,
I actually passed nothing,
they just pushed me through
because I was
at a public school,
and they're just like, "Get
them the fuck outta here."
Right?
Mount Ida College
I was planning
on not going to college,
I was just going to
work in the liquor store
and build it up,
pay back my parents.
My mom's like, "Fuck you,
you're going to college."
I'm like, "Fuck."
I'm like, "How the
fuck am I going to college?"
I'm like, I'm ranked
270 out of 273 in my class.
Right?
I got a 1.4 grade point average,
and I can't put two
sentences together, right?
I get a postcard in the
mail from Mount Ida College.
I fill out my name
and address and send it,
and I get a thing
back, like, "You're in."
That's where I went to college.
(group laughter)
But, what's crazy about that is
through self-awareness,
through recognizing
the world was changing,
through knowing
who and what I was...
The only reason I was so bad
was I was milking that time
because that was
my last vacation.
I was milking high
school and college.
People always
ask me when I talk,
"What did you major in?"
I'm like, "Madden."
(group laughter)
So, that's why
self-awareness is cool.
When you really know yourself...
It's crazy to me how much
money I leave on the table
because I love the game,
or I'd rather spend
the hour doing this than...
Once you know yourself,
and I've been
doing this my whole life,
not "after I made it."
I was paying myself
$30,000 a year
building a big business
because I didn't need stuff.
The money's not
driving me, the game.
A kid saying...
I was laughing
when he just said,
"Coming to New York and meeting
a very important person."
I'm like "Me? Important?
This is funny-ass shit."
That's cool,
making an impact, right?
That's what you
guys are trading on.
That impact is crazy.
What I figured out is
fuck, I can have both.
Right? I'm building an
empire and making an impact
because of the way
it's all worked out.
And now I'm getting greedy.
I'm penetrating
hip hop and sports
so that I can get my message
out at scale to you guys.
'Cause I'm gonna
use Kyle and Logic,
and those guys, you know?
- [Man 4] He's my man!
- [Man 5] You know Kyle?
- Mhmmm, I sure do.
Kyle's right in that
office the other day.
- [Man 5] Ah, man, wow.
- [CJ] So, let me ask you about
self-awareness real quick
because I think
one of the things...
I'm always talking about
how relationships are king
in the classroom over
content, all the time.
- [Gary] Relationships
are the game of life.
- And so, like--
- [Gary] You should go shake
the hand of every business
owner in your neighborhood.
It would change
your life, one weekend.
Would change your life.
- [CJ] Why?
- Because if they're running
a business that's not out
of business,
they know something.
They're doing
something productive.
And I'm again,
making assumptions based on
what you told me.
If it's in tough
neighborhoods, they're grinding.
You know, they got stories,
they got scars.
And by the way,
they would appreciate it.
Like when you're hustling,
you got your corner bodega,
you got a barbershop.
You got a young kid
come through and just say,
"I just want to shake your hand.
"Congrats on this
business, I'm proud of you."
They'll just be happy.
And they may want to
do something for you.
Karma's practical,
doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
That's why.
- [Woman 2] Gratitude, you
talk a lot about gratitude.
- Of course cause if you
all of a sudden just shake
some guys hand, and that
guys like, that's memorable
and he lives a
couple blocks away
and then something happens.
And then like for some
reason Calvin Klein is the
boss of, that's how shit works.
That's how the world works.
That's why, and
it's a nice thing to do.
I just think those business
owners would appreciate it.
You never know when that
may stumble into something.
You know, you do it,
person's caught off-guard
'cause it's weird, like
who the fuck does that right?
So they don't really
react, you leave, but then a
week later you're
walking by with your boys.
They're like, hey!
They grab you and they're
like, tell me about yourself.
And you're like,
we love to do music.
They're like, my
cousin owns a studio
you want some free time?
Off a thank you.
- [CJ] That's
why I gotta make sure
my students know that too.
- When they pop?
(laughing)
When they put you on?
- [CJ] Yeah.
So when did you realize that
self-awareness was important
because I think that's
something I talk about in
class a lot, the
importance of that.
And I think it scares people,
the idea that like you're
gonna admit that there are
things that I'm not good at.
- [Gary] When I got
into the business world,
I started spending a lot of
time very closely with people
and would hear them talk,
and go oh shit
they're wrong about themselves.
I didn't know I
had it, I didn't even
know if I knew the word.
But it became like, delusional.
Somebody who's a
hypocrite, drives me crazy.
Scares the fuck,
I'm visceral to it.
So, which is why when I say
shit like when you call in my
show, and I'm
like you're coming?
I laugh because
I always think the other person
always thinks is
this really gonna happen?
- [Woman] Totally.
(group laughter)
- [CJ] It's been 10 minutes,
they have not
sent me anything yet
you know, what's
going on. (group laughter)
- [Gary] So like to me everybody
is so used to people letting
them down, and this and that.
So anyway, when
did I first learn it?
When I got to really
know people in business.
In life, as a kid in college,
it didn't mean anything to me.
That was like life.
But when I got into business
and be like I can do that
and be like what,
you think you can?
It started getting
weird to me that people were
so confused about
what they were good at
and what they were bad at.
Because now I was in the
zone of me just doing me.
I stay in my lane.
Like real fucking tight.
Like I know what I am.
I know what I wish I was, we
all wish we were something.
So that's when
it started becoming.
- [CJ] So when everyone's lying
to themselves about who they
are how do you really
start figuring out who you are?
- [Gary] You as a person?
- Yes.
- For these guys?
- [CJ] I think these guys are
like, I hear 90% of the dudes
I talk to either wanna be a
rapper, or a football player.
And it's like, are
you on the football team?
Nah, nah, no.
Not this year, I'm gonna go
out next year, and its like
but I don't understand
how you're gonna be the
greatest if your
not doing anything.
- [Gary] Look, my move, and
you know this cause you watch.
And I don't know if you have
air cover to do this move.
The only thing that I've
ever seen work is, when he
says no not this year,
I'm going out next year
I'm like you're fucking full
of shit, you fucking suck.
- [CJ] No I can do that.
- Good.
(group laughter)
- By the way that's
the only thing that works
is suffocating people.
Put them on full blast.
- Can I ask something?
- Hell yeah, that's
what we're here for.
- Alright so, you know how
you boast about having others
technology and everything.
So you're saying now
I won't have to do things
that peoples parents might've
had to do like deal drugs
or like go out there in
the street and do whatever.
Because we got so much of
this, we can make more money
you know, flipping
simple stuff, and you know
going out and earning it.
- [Gary] Yep.
- So like,
you can take
any steps like its gonna take
maybe 100 times, but you'll
probably get it sooner or later?
- My belief is that if
you're a great drug dealer,
you'd be a great businessman.
- I just believe that
'cause it's the same game.
You're selling,
you're workin' it.
Listen, the only friends
I had were drug dealers.
If you're good at that,
I'm sayin' there's a lot
of drug dealers that suck at it.
(group laughter)
Right?
All the kids that I really
hung onto in friendships,
I'm like look at my man Moose.
He's breaking down
these bags into nickels
because he's making more money
that way and he's chincing,
he's actually
making three dollar bags,
but he realizes that
everybody at the school
doesn't know the fuckin'
difference, doesn't care.
He's smart.
And then I would
see other people
who'd like buy like a ounce
and fuckin' smoke 3/4 of it
in four minutes and
then be bad at flippin'
and I was like
he's a fuckin' loser.
So if you're good at it
or if somebody's good at it,
they'd be even better at
flipping sneakers or gear
or going to the
thrift store and flipping
because it's the
same fuckin' move.
And then when you
have the freedom of being
not scared to get caught, now
you're fuckin' movin' fast.
Because when you're
selling drugs you gotta think
about that extra
dimension of getting caught.
But when you're
selling fuckin' t-shirts,
now you're a fuckin'
entrepreneur and people put
you on a pedestal.
So yes, I believe that.
(group laughter)
- I love 'em, I love 'em.
- I believe it 'cause it's true.
'Cause it's fuckin' true
because the kids that I knew
that sold drugs for real
and were real good at it,
have gone on to be much
more successful in the world
than the ones that didn't.
Like it's just a hustle,
you got people skills.
You see angles, that's the
same shit that's like fuck,
this thrift store keeps gettin'
their fuckin' merchandise
and they put it out
at 9:30 in the morning.
I'm gonna go there 'cause
there might be some Nikes,
but it's just hard work.
When you realize how
much more money you can make,
how much good can
happen from hard work,
everybody's
willin' to put in the hard.
If I was a real genie
or a real fuckin' Yoda
and I was like yo,
check this out, watch this,
and you saw you and you
were like, what the fuck?
And you saw you and
it's like a good life
and I'm like
here's all you gotta do,
you gotta work
15 hours a day right now
for the next 10 years straight,
you'll do it.
Everybody will do it.
People don't do it
'cause they're not sure
what's on the other side
of it 'cause they said no
before they said yes.
- [Man 5] So,
the question I have,
how did you avoid the trap by
not doing what your friends did?
- [Gary] I had good
parenting, that's the truth.
My mom instilled so
much self esteem in me,
I thought I was
Superman, that's the truth.
I thought I was the best.
Now whether my mom did that
or it was my natural chemicals
or like I predicted the future,
I just thought I was the best
and once you think you're
the best, you don't give a.
Who the fuck are you
to say that I'm whack?
I'm stupid or I'm a nerd,
I don't give a fuck.
I'll see you at the
finish line, partner.
(group laughter)
You know like
that was my mentality.
That was my mentality.
I'm real glad that high school's
gonna be the
highlight of your fuckin' life.
Like you better
really, really, really enjoy
these 48 months 'cause you're
gonna fuckin' suck in life.
That's how I thought,
I was competitive about it,
if anybody came at me.
What's crazy is,
what's really interesting is,
nobody really came at.
When you're nice and
you're not bothering anybody
and you're just in your
own shit and you're nice.
Not even like you're quiet,
but you're in your own shit,
you're nice,
you're nice to everybody,
nobody's gonna be
real mad at you that.
I didn't drink, I didn't,
people like make a joke here and
there, but they didn't have
real juice behind it, you know?
Nobody really bothered me.
You know, but listen,
I have empathy like listen,
I have no idea
where you guys are from,
but I have some friends
from some fucked up places
where it wasn't that easy.
Like when you were 12
and 13 you were gettin'
recruited to do some
shit and it wasn't as easy
to just be like
I'm doin' my own thing.
So listen, I'm always
careful when I don't know
the backstories
or every detail.
So I could do it,
I wasn't recruited to do some
fuckin' crazy shit, you know?
If you're lucky enough
to not be recruited by local
gangs to do shit well
then you have no excuses
because my
big thing is (sigh),
you're either gonna define
yourself for yourself or
you're gonna let
someone else define you.
You're either gonna
let your mom define you,
your dad define you,
your grandparents define you,
your older brother,
your older sister,
dude from around the way,
somebody's gonna define you
or you're gonna define yourself.
I'm just tryin' to figure
out how to hack at you
to make you define yourself,
for yourself, in yourself,
within yourself, and then,
then shit changes.
- [Man 8] Yeah,
I got a question.
- Yeah, my man.
- [Man 8] How do you keep that
motivation and keep grinding
and working hard
and doing those...
- [Gary] I have no choice.
I've got no choice.
- When you have
multiple things...
- [Gary] 'Cause I'm trying to,
'cause I don't think
I'm anything yet man.
If I told you what was in my
head, you would not believe me.
- [CJ] In terms of
greatness you're talking about?
- Yeah.
I'm not,
you know, I'm not naive.
I know I've made a lot of money.
I'm starting to make an impact
but I don't read my
own press clippings.
I wasn't joking
when I was laughing
when you said that
the important person.
Like I mean it,
that wasn't for show
that's just what
goes through my body.
I believe it,
like I believe that.
My ambition is
as great as it gets.
I think I can go down all time.
If I can stay alive
'cause I know I wanna
do good and be great.
I wanna be great, I can do both.
I'm weird, I can do both.
The reason I can
be good for people
is I'm so good at my craft.
I can put 80% of
my energy against it
and achieve more
than everybody else,
which then leaves me so
much room to do other shit.
Do you know what I want?
And you've heard this I think.
Do you know what I'm
really am doing here?
I'm trying to sucker one of
you to come to my funeral.
- [Man 4] I saw
your sign outside.
- That's my jam my man.
If I said something here
that fucking triggered a
different chemical in your brain
and you went on
to have a great life
and I think I'm
gonna be pretty damn famous
by the time I die and you hear
I'm dead, you might be like,
"I should probably go
to that man's funeral.
"He changed my life."
You take your kid and tell
them the story, that's cool.
My grandkids get to see you
flew from, you know, Texas
to come to my
funeral in New York.
And telling stories of
how I changed your life,
that's the greatest
legacy of all time.
There's only one way to do that.
You gotta give.
What's that my man?
- I said I missed the prom.
I was suppose to go on
somebody's prom or whatever.
Well my
girlfriend at the time...
- [Gary] (laughs) Thank God
you said at the time
otherwise you wouldn't be here.
- I know I made the
right decision, so thanks.
- [Gary] My man of course.
I'm glad you're here.
- She hates you now.
(group laughter)
One less person at your funeral.
- [Gary] I'll get to her.
I'll get to her.
- [Woman] Before we wrap up,
can you talk about, real
fast with these guys about,
you talk a lot about
not being number one.
It's not always
about being number one.
Can it be about being 25?
- [Gary] I think you should
strive to be number one
and be realistic if
you're number 14,000.
Like you gotta try.
- [Woman] Sure, but
it's not a bad thing
to not be number one.
- No, and I think,
you know what's funny?
I think I threw that in
there when I talked earlier
about being the
18,000th best entrepreneur.
It's you know, yeah
I think that's right.
And I think where you're
going and I believe in this,
which is too many
people try to be number one
and then if not
they wanna be zero.
It's like this
all or nothing game.
It's just a false game
and it's not practical.
It's not real life.
So listen, I'm really
glad you guys came through.
We can do this again.
You know everybody's
got their own style.
A lot of people,
some people ask questions,
other people are
a little more quiet.
You can hit me up on DM.
Just make sure you starred it
'cause I only see
the first couple words.
Make sure you starred
that you're part of this crew.
I know not everybody wants
to share their shit out loud.
But I'm thrilled to bring
anybody in this room value.
- I have a selfish
question 'cause I didn't talk.
If I'm trying to
build my YouTube channel,
I'm trying to do
every single thing
that I hear you saying.
- [Gary] There is only
one answer, collaborations.
- Alright, that's
what I'm doing, alright.
- [Gary] That's it.
- Alright.
- Hit up just
like everybody else,
every single YouTube celebrity
that lives in Philadelphia
should hear from you.
Have them come through
the school, go to trick shots
in the fucking
courtyard with them.
Whatever it takes.
Siphon audience from them.
You're now gonna
put this video up.
It's gonna have my name in it.
My name gets searched on
YouTube trillions of times.
In the eternity, one of
the right people looks at it
from four years
from now and away you go.
- [CJ] True, Gary we got this.
I like to give people pictures
of my own face sometimes.
So all the guys signed it.
- [Gary] Ah, I love this.
- [CJ] And just to say thanks.
- [Gary] I appreciate it.
My man, good luck to you.
- [Man 9] Gary,
you read my mind.
- Yeah, of course my man.
- You sign this?
- [Gary] I'll do better
than that. You know what?
Come with me in my office,
I'll let them sign up,
I'll sign you guys all a book.
(upbeat music)